if you're tired of your bank ripping you
off click the link below to learn about
our sponsor current which is an awesome
alternative to dealing with big banks
I'll tell you more about them at the end
of the video ok so in the last 24 hours
the health questions about Donald Trump
have appeared not just on Fox News as we
already talked about but the health
questions around Trump has also become a
focus of a new ad from the Republican
pack Republican political action
committee called the Lincoln project now
we've talked about the Lincoln project a
little bit before it's a pack run by
some prominent Republicans this includes
George Conway who by the way is the
husband of Trump advisor Kellyanne
Conway a Steve Schmidt is part of the
Lincoln project former McCain campaign
manager Rick Wilson and other prominent
Republicans they are a Republican pack
that realizes Trump is a danger and must
be removed their ads have been going
after Trump harder and harder and
yesterday they released an ad that goes
after Donald Trump on the topic of his
health again raising questions about
Trump's behavior over the weekend at
West Point linking Trump's behavior to
the last-minute visit to Walter Reed
Medical Center in 2019 so let's look at
the ad let's listen to the ad now some
of these elements are visual like for
example you'll hear voice over and they
are showing Donald Trump acting
bizarrely
so I do recommend watching this online
but you'll get a sense of the story
that's being told from the narration
let's take a look something's wrong with
Donald Trump he's shaky weak trouble
speaking trouble walking so why are we
talking about this and why isn't the
press covering Trump secretive midnight
run to Walter Reed Medical Center why do
so many reporters who cover the White
House pretend they
see Trump's decline the most powerful
office in the world needs more than a
week
unfit shaky President Trump doesn't have
the strength to lead nor the character
to admit it we're not doctors but we're
not blind it's time we talk about this
Trump is not well so this is really
quite well done even the details doubt
that down to the details it's very good
at one point when the voice-over says we
are not doctors what you see in the ad
is Trump's old dr. Harold Bornstein on
screen that's the guy that Donald Trump
allegedly coerced into writing that
bogus letter about how healthy Donald
Trump is so we are now seeing this I
guess we would call it a sort of hashtag
movement Trump is not well is the name
of it and it's going much more
mainstream than it ever has it's
happening thanks to right-wing media
it's happening thanks to a Republican
political action committee and to go
back to the analysis this is not about
Republicans are now going to be widely
concerned about Donald Trump's health
that's not going to happen the
importance of this is that there are
large swaths of the American population
that don't even know that there's been a
conversation about Trump's health
happening for three years there's large
portions of the electorate that have no
idea that dozens of medical experts both
from the Naropa neurology field and
mental health fields have been
expressing concern about Donald Trump's
health for years because they watch Fox
News and they only follow Republicans on
social media they don't know about
Trump's verbal glitches his wandering
off that time when he came off of Air
Force One his limo was right in front of
him he wandered off had to be brought
back by Secret Service losing his train
of thought sweating with the dilated
pupils while speaking upper Trump versus
downer Trump they don't know about it so
even hearing about this as a thing on
Fox News and through a Republican pack
is introducing it into their awareness
now 99% of them won't care but remember
that in 2016 the election came down to
75,000 votes
in three states we will mostly win if we
get the turnout but we'll take any help
we can get and if it's a Republican pack
and FoxNews asking even some questions
about Donald Trump's health you might
convince a few people and we will take
it now there are reports about this ad
being controversial for example this
there's an article this morning in the
week which is called new Lincoln project
ad controversial II questions Trump's
health it's not really controversial if
you've been following this for years and
there's a debate happening in this
article and elsewhere asking whether
Trump's health is fair game
now one argument is listen Trump mocked
a disabled reporter he calls Joe Biden's
sleepy Joe and says Joe Biden doesn't
even know what he's saying he is
regularly implying Joe Biden is
cognitively impaired so that makes
Trump's health fair game
I disagree with that assessment the
reason Trump's health is fair game is
because he's the president and we have
reason to believe that he's lying about
his health his medical report lied about
his height and weight combination he
allegedly coerced the doctor to write a
letter saying Trump would be the
healthiest president in history it's an
empirical claim that no doctor could
actually make so I understand the
concern from disability rights groups
worried that this is bordering on making
fun of health issues that is not what
this is about
this is about understanding the critical
nature of being president and when you
have a president that number one seems
unwell and number two is dishonest about
everything including his height and
weight we are absolutely right to be
concerned that's really what this is
fundamentally about it's no secret on
the show that I am very critical of the
big banks and how they screw over
customers in so many ways and if you're
like me you're probably sick of the fees
and the hassles that come with a
checking account at a big traditional
bank by now in that case check out the
online bank current they're one of our
sponsors if you're watching on YouTube
this here is my actual debit card
my current checking account which I'm
holding up with current you've got no
minimum balance no overdraft fees up to
$100 no ATM fees you can use over 55,000
ATMs nationwide unlike with other banks
you receive your direct deposit
instantly meaning you'll get paid by
your employer up to two days sooner you
can deposit checks instantly using your
camera phone 24/7 member support and
unlike with other banks current
instantly refunds that hold on your card
when you pump gas you can pause your
debit card instantly which is really
useful there are just so many different
advantages to ditching the big banks and
instead use a bank that puts their
members first it takes two minutes to
sign up they'll immediately ship you
your debit card for free go ahead and
get started by clicking the link down
below the video